en Ukraine l'Ukraine ou Kiev poursuit
son offensive et affirme avancer sur le
front sud près de Robotis na Kiev on
retrouvait manuel Chaze notre
correspondante Emmanuel bonjour les
troupes ukrainiennes s'enfonce donc dans
les lignes de défense russe près de ce
village de robotine qu'elle revendique
avoir repris hier
oui tout à fait ça d'abord été la
déclaration de la ministre délégal à
défense à la Malia qui a effectivement
lundi confirmé cette prise cette
libération de robottines et par les
troupes ukrainiennes alors ça avait été
observé par par des experts
internationaux qui voyaient ses avancées
de des forces ukrainiennes dans
robottines il a fallu attendre jusqu'à
lundi pour la confirmation et
aujourd'hui un porte-parole militaire a
également confirmé que les troupes
allaient plus loin qu'elle
consolidait les acquis arrobotinés et
qu'elle continuait d'avancer vers la
première ligne de défense russe alors
robottiner c'est un village en soit
avant guerre il n'était pas forcément
important il est devenu parce que c'est
là où se trouvait où se concentrer
énormément de soldats russes énormément
de matériel donc c'est une prise
importante robottines avait été discuté
depuis des semaines des mois même par
l'armée ukrainienne
en continuant vers en continuant après
robot ciné ça veut dire que les forces
ukrainiennes se rapprochent de leur but
qui est de couper les lignes
d'approvisionnement russe une nouvelle
avancée et pourtant Emmanuel certains
observateurs ont relevé les difficultés
rencontrées par l'armée ukrainienne et
quels sont-elles exactement
alors c'est vrai que en dehors de
l'Ukraine à l'extérieur on a beaucoup
entendu des critiques des doutes
vis-à-vis de ces opérations offensives
ukrainiennes beaucoup ont parlé de
lenteur mais qui est sans défend puisque
l'armée ukrainienne rencontre des
difficultés sur le terrain le pays est
lourdement miné notamment tout au long
de ces lignes de défense russe que les
forces russes ont eu plus d'un an donc
ont eu beaucoup de temps pour fortifier
néanmoins ce qu'on observe aussi c'est
que ces fortifications russes et bien ne
sont pas égales on voit également que
les forces russes
envoient en fait du renfort sur les
points les plus sensibles dont la
direction de robottiner depuis d'autres
positions de la ligne de front donc une
armée russe qui peine à contenir cette
saisonienne donc oui des difficultés
sont rencontrées par l'armée ukrainienne
ça ne correspond pas pas forcément en
calendrier kvfxé et que c'était fixé
plutôt l'Occident mais pour Kiev il
s'agit d'avancer régulière et en cela
est constituent un succès pour le
gouvernement ukrainien merci beaucoup
Emmanuel chaise en direct de Kia fourni
Kren et dans